كان الموقع مازال قيد الاخلاء عندما وصلنا
اليه بعد عده دقائق من انفجار في هذه
المنطقه امام مبنى حكومي محمد اغا كان
قريبا عندما حدث
الهجوم رايت عده اكياس مليئه باشلاء بشريه
كانوا يحملونها ثم اتت سياره الاسعاف الى
المكان حفره قريبه من المكان الذي وقع فيه
الانفجار وعلى ما يبدو فان القنبله كانت
مخباه بداخل حف
صغيره اعضاء الامن هنا متوترون ويمكنك
رؤيه قوه تاثير الانفجار من خلال النظر
الى هذا المبنى الذي تحطمت نوافذه
والاسوار المحيطه به وهناك الكثير من
الاشلاء هنا كما تشاهدون امام مبنى وزاره
الداخليه القديمه هذا هو ثاني انفجار كبير
خلال يومين فقط في دمشق الكثير من سكان
سوريا يعتقدون بان هجمات مشابهه لتلك التي
تحدث في العراق ستكون اكثر شيوعا في سوريا
هذه
الايام انهم يقتلون شعبنا الولايات
المتحده تعلم بانهم ارهابيون فلماذا
يقومون بدعمهم الولايات المتحده تقول انها
تقدم دعما غير فتاك للمعارضه فقط وبجانب
المحادثات السياسيه فان بعض السوريين مثل
هذه السيده مصدومون مما يحدث في
بلادهم نل اونا عم نل بعضنا نح
ويبدو ان التفجيرات لم تثبت من عزيمه مؤيد
بشار الاسد كما يظهر من هتافات هؤلاء
السوريين سوريا
بشار الله سوريا